tretinoin a japine tartin these drug
retinoids are some of the most powerful
ingredients in skincare and the right
one can really transform your skin but
what's the difference between them and
which one should you use and what is
with all the different formulations I'm
Michelle I have a PhD in Medicinal
Chemistry and I'm a qualified cosmetic
chemist I've seen so many myths around
drug rid and I get so many questions
about which one works best for what like
does AD dafine do anything for
anti-aging or does it just work for acne
is tranon the best all around a retinoid
today I'm going to break down the
differences between the drug retinoids
and all the different formulas which one
works best for acne wrinkles pigment and
I'll debunk a whole bunch of myths about
these ingredients along the way let's
get into it so let's start with Treon it
is the oldest it was approved in the
1960s so it has been studied the most
most of the evidence we have on
retinoids are based on tretinoin so we
know that it works for all the standard
of retinoid things like acne pigment and
wrinkles but there are also studies on
more unusual things like skin cancer
stretch marks and cellulite it's the
drug retinoid that has the biggest
variety of formulas you can get
concentrations between 0.025 and .1 and
it's compounded a lot so you can control
the percent there too although what that
percent actually means is a bit of a
question mark because compounding is all
question marks check out my video on
drug versus cosmetic retinoids for more
on that some studies sort of suggest
that if you have a low concentration
it'll end up working as well as a higher
concentration it might just take a bit
longer but they will be less iritating
you can get tranon in gels and creams
and there are some studies that indicate
that cream bases might be less
irritating but my personal conspiracy
theory is that having a cream formula
might just be forcing people in these
studies to use moisturizer because it is
basically just a moisturizing base the
reason I have this theory is that a lot
of these studies don't actually give
people moisturizer to use and a lot of
the people in these studies are like
teenage boys or men in their early 20s
with acne and that is just not a
demographic that we know goes out and
uses moisturizer of their own accord
unless you know you actually tell them
to use moisturizer a lot of the retinoid
irritation is from barrier disruption
and we know that moisturizers can help
with that so maybe gels are fine as well
as long as you moisturize better than
like a teenage boob with acne there are
some fancier versions like Al trano
which has that nicer lotion base it's
less irritating there's incapsulated
versions like retina micro which are
usually gentler because they basically
wrap up the tranon and then release it
more slowly a Vita gel also has a
polymer that releases the tranon slower
as well there are also combination
formulas that are really handy for some
issues so for acne treone is really nice
because it breaks up the clogged pores
and so that helps other ingredients
penetrate better benzol peroxide
destroys some other ingredients
including Tron but they are both really
good for acne so twio is a newer formula
that has tranon and benzol peroxide and
those are encapsulated separately in
silica it's kind of like if you have
Bubble tea with two different flavored
popping pearls they are separated until
you mash them together in your mouth or
you're mashing these two ingredients
onto your skin triple therapy creams are
used for fading pigment and they combine
trome with a tyrosinase inhibitor so
hydroquinone and a corticosteroid that
reduces inflammation so it's almost like
a teamwork approach to targeting
different parts of the pigment
production process except in this team
everyone actually pitches in and because
treeson is older then there are a lot
more generic versions of a lot of these
formulas which can end up cheaper so why
are there newer retinoids it's because
tranon is really annoying first off it
is pretty unstable so it breaks down
pretty quickly if you have light if you
have heat if you have oxygen it's not
like you have to turn off the light
before you put it on or like try not to
breathe but it's more about making the
product more stable inside the tube
there's been a lot of effort that's been
put into making more stable formulas it
also gets broken down by benzol peroxide
like I mentioned before so you can't
really layer them together you do have
to buy a special formula treone is also
pretty irritating people in clinical
trials and in real life give up on it
all the time before it really has a
chance to work and there are ways to
make tanol formulas more stable and less
irritating but you can also build these
into the active ingredient itself and
that is what all these newer retinoids
are about here is where receptors come
in retinoids work by binding to retinoid
receptors in the skin and again the
renoid is like a key that binds to the
receptor lock and that makes something
happen so it's the microscopic changes
that eventually build up to give you
those skin benefits there are three
subtypes of these receptors that are
slightly different shapes they're sort
of like slightly different shaped locks
and they are called alpha beta and gamma
scientists are bad at coming up with
names that is why my channel is called
lab muffin gamma are the main ones in
skin and they are responsible for a lot
of those skin benefits maybe all of them
Alpha is also in skin and there's a bit
more in the dermis than the epidermis
beta isn't really in skin that much and
it's generally thought that they just
aren't that important for skin benefits
tonone will bind to all three and I've
seen people saying that this is a good
thing because it means that tonone will
work for more things but that's just not
how it works that's not how any of this
works in Medicinal Chemistry if you have
an ingredient binding to more things
that is generally something you want to
avoid most drugs work mostly at one
receptor type and when it hits all the
other ones that is usually when you get
more side effects the technical term for
this is promiscuous it's almost like
medicinal chemists are trying to
chain the m into behaving better are we
so a lot of drug design is about
making ingredients buy more to the good
luck and less to everything else so
following this logic drug companies
started inventing ingredients that bound
more to gamma and less to Alpha to try
to keep those same benefits with tranon
but with less irritation and that's how
we came up with adapalene and Tartine
both of these have aromatic rings in
their structures which are these
hexagons that makes them more rigid so
they don't fit into as many locks as
tonon which is is kind of floppy both of
them bind to gamma and beta much more
than Alpha the technical term for this
is they are more selective so I guess
they have like higher standards these
Rings also make them more stable so
that's really handy for making easier
formulas and also mixing with things
like benzol peroxide but it could
actually also make them less irritating
because when tranon breaks down it turns
into stuff that could potentially be
irritating skin so did this actually
work adap is less irritating in clinical
Tri and anecdotally so yay science Works
yes science but with Tartine there's a
bunch of like early studies that said it
was around as irritating as tranon and
adapalene but then later studies and
like every dermatologist you talk to and
everyone who's tried to zarine they will
all tell you that it's more irritating
it's kind of sad to read through the
studies in date order and just sort of
see all the Hope just slowly fade so it
just doesn't seem like there's some sort
of straightforward relationship between
receptors and irritation which makes
sense because a lot of retinoid
irritation seems to come from just
literally how they work so the gamma
receptor both giveth and taketh away
from looking at all the evidence I think
irritation and a lot of the other
differences like which one works best
for what most of that actually comes
from other factors like where the
ingredient actually ends up in the skin
and a lot of this is based on things
like molecular size and solubility it's
called pharmacokinetics and also just
what formulations and strengths that you
can get them in there's actually a 2023
study that found that a newer
0.045% Tartine lotion was less
irritating than trifarotene and
adapalene and this kind of backs me up I
found this study after I wrote this part
so that was really quite nice for my
impostor syndrome let's take a closer
look at adoline maybe not that close
that funky Cube thing is called
adamantine and it makes the overall
molecule more oil soluble and that helps
it go into hair follicles more which is
good because that is where the pimples
live live they've also messed around
with the particle size and different to
make it do that more too the other cool
thing is that this extra oil solubility
makes us stay in the skin rather than
absorbing deeper into like your more
watery bits like blood and that makes it
safer that extra safety is actually why
you can get 0.1% ad daping gel over the
counter in some places like the US which
is where I got this one from an alter
the other versions of AD daping are
prescription though the stability from
these Rings also makes it really good
for acne because it means you can layer
it with B or peroxide and you can also
get it in a relatively simple combo
formula which is called Epiduo C xartin
looks like this again we have the
aromatic rings for stability and
rigidity but you can also see there's a
nitrogen and a sulfur those help your
body in activator faster if it ends up
absorbing into your blood so again it's
for safety in the original papers they
also thought that it might help it be
less irritating but obviously that just
did not pan out Tartine is interesting
because it is a prodrug that means that
it isn't actually active until enzymes
break off that little thing on the right
part which is called an ethyl group this
turns it into tazarotenic acid which is
the actual active thing and that happens
within minutes so this busts another
retinoid myth that I have seen a lot
that drug retinoids are more effective
because they are already in their active
form Tartine here is inactive and it is
considered by a lot of people to be the
strongest retinoid I've even seen this
from a dermatologist on the official
differ site which is special but yeah
basically Superman isn't weaker and some
random buff guy just because he starts
off as Clark H he still ends up as
Superman Tartine is a bit harder to find
but there are still some interesting
formulas it's usually at .1% in a gell
or cream but there's also a foam formula
which is pretty cool and there's the
newer
0.045% lotion I talked about it before
it's called araso and it has a polymer
in it that helps distribute the Tartine
and the hydrating ingredients in it more
evenly on skin and help it get into skin
impressively there is a manufacturer
funder study where it was less
irritating and more effective than a
standard. 1% tartin cream which is
pretty cool finally we have Tri faratin
and this one was approved in 2019 this
was purposely designed to be even more
selective for gamma receptors that blue
bit there makes it not fit into Alpha
and beta very well again the reasoning
was that maybe if we have even more
selectivity then it would decrease side
effects but that logic just doesn't
really work adap and tartin are both
more selective for beta than gamma and
they kind of just went in opposite
directions when it came to irritation
but they started developing Tri faratin
in the mid90s before they really worked
out this whole like Tartine Paradox and
it does have different properties so
that could actually make it less
irritating again tritin is designed to
be safer those orange bits there make it
easier for your liver to inactivate it
if it gets into your blood and it's
actually so safe that it's been
specifically approved for truncal acne
so like your chest and back because it's
safer you can apply more of it on a
larger surface area area compared to if
it was just approved for your face it is
a lot more potent which is why it's at
such a low concentration but because it
is new there is only this one
formulation the brand name is called
aclea and it's got a polymer in it that
again spreads out the active more evenly
it's also got alent toome which is
soothing now before we get into which
retinoid is best for what let's quickly
run through some myths that you'll see
online now receptors I have come across
some stuff about how different retinoid
receptors are best for particular things
but it is pretty much all about Gamma
all of them mostly work by binding to
gamma again any differences we have are
probably more about where the
ingredients end up in the skin the
concentrations you have and the
formulations you have drug approvals and
clinical studies so a lot of people talk
about what each renoid is approved for
and how many clinical trials there are
for each particular one these are
helpful but just like for rol it is
really important to think about the
context less data doesn't mean that
something is less effective and there
are a lot of practical considerations
when it comes to clinical trials and
Drug approvals for drug approvals it is
easier to measure big differences for
acne in a short time frame compared to
something like Photo aging and that is
probably why all the retinoids are
approved for acne companies also need to
collect and decide to submit the data to
get a drug approved for a particular
thing and that costs money it might not
be worth it and Drug approvals don't
just look at Effectiveness they also
take into account things like whether or
not there are existing treatments and
what sort of public need there is drugs
also approve for different things and
different regions and all of this mess
is why doctors prescribe things off
label all the time so they're using it
for a benefit that isn't officially
approved for clinical trials again there
is a lot of like important context not
every clinical trial has the same chance
of getting funded and published tranon
is the oldest so it's been approved and
studied for the most things but if you
look at studies where tranon has been
compared to another renoid head-to-head
it usually loses although that might
also be biased because a lot of these
studies are fun of by the manufacturers
of the new retinoids and then there are
also some brands of tranon that are
approved for photoaging but then other
ones aren't anyway the point is it is
really messy so don't take any of it too
seriously think of it more as like
indications rather than black and white
hard cut facts irritation so there is
this misconception that more irritating
means more effective but that is just
not what the evidence shows from the
least to the most irritating the general
trend is adapalene and then tranon and
then Tartine is the most irritating
there isn't that much evidence on Tri
faratin but it does seem to be on like
the less irritating end and of course it
also depends on the formula so there is
this myth that a japine is the least
effective because it's the least
irritating but irritation doesn't just
happen from hitting that gamma receptor
it's a lot of other effects as well
clinical trials have generally found
that 1% of dappling is about as
effective for acne as 0.025% treso but
with a lot less irritation so which
froid is best for what
again it is best to consult a
dermatologist who can help you work out
which product best suits your needs and
situation but this is just general info
thanks to Dr Mara of Dermatology for
checking over this for me so with acne
all of the rids are approve for acne
adapalene is really optimized for acne
treatment it is stable to benzol
peroxide and the particle size indiffer
is specifically made so that it ends up
going into hair follicles which is where
the pimples live it is also easier to
get in some places if you have it over
the counter triar is the only one that's
been specifically approved for body acne
but there is only one formula and there
are no generics tranon is generally more
irritating and it is unstable with
benzol peroxide but for a lot of people
it is the easiest drug retinoid to get
there are some studies that found that
tartin was the most effective retinoid
for acne but not by a lot and irritation
is usually an issue now for wrinkles and
texture tranon and Tartine are both
approved for treating signs of sun
damage like wrinkling and roughness
there are study showing that they work
for other types of hyperpigmentation too
including post acne marks in Darker skin
irritation and rebound pigment gets
pointed out as an issue a lot so keep
that in mind and maybe look for a
gentler formula tranon is also in those
triple therapy creams adapalene again
isn't approved for treating pigment but
there are some studies with promising
results in general though it doesn't
seem to work as well as those two
although there is less irritation
Tartine again it is new there's no
clinical trials but it did reduce
pigment in animal model when it was
being developed so where to start in
general adling is one of the best
beginner options you can get it over the
counter in some places and because
irritation is such a big problem for
most people starting on retinoids tranon
is another good starting point for most
people because it is so widely available
it's also really well studied although
it is quite irritating and not that
stable Tartine is usually more
irritating so it is usually recommended
after people have already used retinoids
for a while Tartine might be a good
option but it is less studied and less
available in general you probably want
to start with a lower concentration for
whichever retinoid you have drug or
cosmetic and then slowly move up now
converting between percentages of
different rosid I see a lot of stuff
online about how like 0.1 a japine is
the same as 025 tranon or whatever but
this is all really super handwavy
clinical trials only really use
concentrations that you can actually get
so for Treon there are like I don't know
five or something but Tartine and
adapalene they only only really come in
two and as we see new formulas coming
out and getting studied it's become
pretty clear that the lowest common
concentration doesn't always mean that
it is the lowest effective concentration
so these comparisons are kind of like
saying my friend and I are exactly as
good at math as each other because there
was one quiz where we got the same Mark
it's just not that useful as an
indicator and we've also got formulation
and formulation just makes a really big
difference there is that 0.045% Tartine
lotion that's meant to be more effective
Ive than .1% there are also similar
studies with different tranon types so
it is just a bit of a mess but Studies
have mostly compared .1% adline with
.25% tanol for acne one study found that
3% adapin is similar to 05% tanol for
photoaging another study found that. 1%
tartin was better than 05% tanol for
photoaging so that is what we have take
that as a very very very rough
indication now before you run off to get
one of these you might want to ask
yourself are drug retinoids even right
for you and what about compounded ones
well I've got a video for you I also
have a video on how to start retinoids
without your skin falling off and my
ebook tells you how to get a skincare
routine going I'll be talking about
cosmetic retinoids soon in the meantime
you can check out my skincare science
playlist thanks to Dr Mara and Ruby for
helping me out on this video you can
also check out the orig version of this
on my website which has more info and
references